mein heutiger gast im dialog ist der
jugendrichter andreas müller durch
einige außergewöhnliche urteile hat er
sich den beinamen deutschlands härtester
richter zugezogen herzlich willkommen
bei phoenix ich bedanke mich dass ich
hier sein darf
herr müller ich möchte mit einem zitat
von ihnen beginnen wenn menschen nachts
angst haben über öffentliche plätze zu
gehen oder mit der s bahn zu fahren dann
läuft etwas gewaltig schief was läuft da
schief dass es so ist läuft schief also
normalerweise dürften wir gar keine s
bahn übergriffe haben wir dürften wir
keine schlägereien im öffentlichen raum
haben wir dürften nicht tagtäglich
gefährliche körperverletzung auf den
straßen haben und was wenn ihr
garantiert nicht haben dürfen ist
natürlich eine angst von menschen die
damit verbunden ist dass sie auch opfer
einer solchen gewalt werden kann diese
angst muss weg jeder der mit der mitte s
bahn fährt der muss sicher sein dass er
heil ankommt und derjenige der seine
kinder los schickt muss sicher sein dass
seine kinder wieder heil ankommen aber
die angst ist da und die vorfälle die
gibt es auch müssen wir das klaglos
hinnehmen oder gibt es möglichkeiten
dagegen vorzugehen
natürlich gibt es möglichkeiten dagegen
vorzugehen
es wird ja auch schon was gemacht aber
ich finde jedes mal ein übergriff so
nenne ich sie den ich verhandelt einer
zu viel
jedes opfer was ich im gerichtssaal war
name ist einer zuviel es kann weiteres
gemacht werden
ich habe einige vorschläge unterbreitet
wir wären sicherlich nicht von heute auf
morgen auf null reduzieren das ist dass
wir eine wunderschöne idealvorstellung
aber wir können tagtäglich weiter daran
arbeiten und ich bin eigentlich im
grunde genommen der festen überzeugung
dass wir so ein etwa fünf sechs jahren
zurückblicken auf das was man denken was
haben wir eigentlich wenn du scheiße
gebaut
das klingt ja sehr interessant ich fange
jetzt mal ganz bei ihnen ganz persönlich
an fahren sie s bahn oder übernachten
sie
nein nicht als ich das letzte mal
versucht das war als wenn kurz bevor ich
das buch aus gebracht habe da bin ich
ganz gefallen hatte auch leicht alkohol
im kopf irgendwie den kreuzberg meiner
alten ecke und hatte drei vier bier im
kopf und hatte mir vorher geschworen
nach dem essen
ich fange taxi und dann habe ich gedacht
ich kann auch wohl die 20 kilometer quer
durch die stadt doch mit der s bahn
fahren und dann bin ich wieder auf seine
jugendgruppe gestoßen und da ging es
eigentlich um folgendes die beobachteten
mich alten herrn
und irgendwie kam es zum gespräch und
was machten sie sie duzen mich zu 16 17
jährige people's und ich entgegnet ob
sie den in ihren eigenen vater auch
dutzend würde ob da nicht ein bisschen
mehr respekt angezeigt und so es geräte
die situation schon ein wenig es kam zur
spannung ich ging und ich merkte schon
dass sie so dass sie mich im ziel
erhalten
ja ich dann vor die s-bahn in den
u-bahnhof war die s-bahn in den s-
bahnhofes stieg aus fragte noch einen
mann neben mir der 1 meter 90 groß war
ob ich nicht neben ihm herlaufen könne
er sagt ich soll lieber alleine gehen
also das war schon wieder brenzlig aber
das ist auch nur bei mir so ich bin so
ein jugendrichter
ich messe 20 jahren nichts anderes als
im jugend richterliche situation zu
beurteilen
schwierigere einfach handeln dies und
jenes und wenn ich gucke ist das ganz
anders also dass es nur auf mich ich
habe jetzt keine besondere angst aber
ich habe manchmal das gefühl der
jugendrichter lebt auch am zweiter und
so ist es für mich persönlich immer
besser doch ein taxi zu nehmen
jugendrichter sind sie inzwischen seit
fast 20 jahren
aber sie haben mal ganz anders
angefangen ich weiß in ihren
anfangszeiten da hatten sie bei der
staatsanwaltschaft den spitznamen der
milde müller inzwischen werden sie
haben wir ja schon erwähnt vereinzelt
als deutschlands härteste richter
bezeichnet wie kommt es dazu dass sie
plötzlich so anders denken also über
milden müller hätte niemand schrieben
melde müller sind für die presse nicht
irgendwie interessant ich war milder
müller habe jetzt tatsächlich im
beinamen auch her das gericht aber ich
hätte schon ganz andere ich hatte nicht
nur her dass der richter auch knallhart
richter dann hatte ich so sachen wie
kreativste richter enfant terrible der
deutschen justiz also ich könnte das
ellen lang auf zählen auch kritischer
richter war dabei am anfang und haben
sie recht
die staatsanwaltschaft der milde müller
ich hatte angefangen mit dem ziel keinen
jungen menschen in den strafvollzug zu
bringen rein mit pädagogik rhein mit
sozialarbeit und rein durch eine gute
ansprache eines pädagogisch versierten
jugendrichter ist so war das ziel
und am anfang habe ich dann natürlich
auch versucht milde walten zu lassen
habe dann allerdings relativ schnell
gemerkt dass nur mit milde kein staat zu
machen ist
ich versuche mal ein beispiel zu
erwähnen dass man versteht wie sie
zumindest manchmal auch wotan da ist der
fall des 19 jährigen daniel der gehörte
zur rechten szene und nach einem
saufgelage hat er bei einem indischen
restaurant die schaufensterscheibe
eingetreten vermutlich aus
rechtsextremen hintergrund gelandete bei
ihnen vor gericht und sie haben ihn
verurteilt zu neun monaten ohne
bewährung das heißt neun monate
jugendstrafanstalt ohne bewährung für
sachbeschädigung das ist ein
außergewöhnliches urteil
es war ein außergewöhnliches schultern
das hatte mehrere komponenten dieses
urteil
er hat nicht nur eine sache beschwerte
noch 1 geschossen wie war es so dass die
indischen werte unheimliche angst hatten
vor weiteren übergriffen ihn mitarbeiter
wollten nicht mehr im lokal
weiterarbeiten
ich habe seinerzeit den weg gemacht dass
einige der normale gewesen sein müsste
ich habe polizei angerufen
staatsanwaltschaft angerufen und hat
gesagt ich will die sache sofort auf den
tisch
zehn tage später hatte ich die sache was
gesetzlich möglich war heute auch
möglich war allerdings kaum praktiziert
wird
auf den tischen habe dann dieses urteil
verkündet habe zeitgleich ein haftbefehl
verkündet wegen fluchtgefahr als
einzelrichter und zehn minuten pause
gemacht eine bin ich wieder rein
gegangen und hat den haftbefehl außer
vollzug gesetzt
das war für daniel schock er hat dann in
der zweiten instanz für eine
bewährungsstrafe bekommt zurecht oder
zwischenzeitlich enorm an sich
gearbeitet hatte aber dieses zwei sachen
gezeigt einerseits ist es manchmal
notwendig härte zu zeigen und
andererseits muss der stadt schnell
arbeiten und schließt sich zeigen
bestimmte urteile auch signalwirkung
auch im jugendstrafrecht etwas verpönt
ist
nach diesem urteil was eben zehn tage
keine aus der rechten szene hatte hatte
sich vorstellen können wie schnell der
zuständige oder die zuständigen im staat
handeln können danach wusste die rechte
szene wie schnell reagieren können
für ihr hartes vorgehen gegen die rechte
szene da haben sie damals sehr viel
beifall erhalten
das hat sich allerdings das mit dem
beifahrer sich sehr schnell geändert als
sie entschieden haben
härte konsequenz hilft nicht nur bei
rechten straftätern sondern auch bei in
anführungszeichen normalen straftätern
ja also das war ja so der kampf gegen
rechtsradikale jung geweiht war
notwendig werden ganz viele sketche auf
der straße die alles angriffen was
anders aus homosexuelle männer menschen
die der punker szene zuzurechnen waren
oder und das war das schlimmste
leute mit dem migrantischen aussehen und
da musste man habe ich im grunde
genommen von insbesondere von den linken
sehr viel beifall bekommen und im laufe
der zeit um auch dem zusammenwirken mit
kisten reisig gab es eben auch andere
jugendgruppengewalt die eben nicht von
rein deutscher jugendlichkeit ausgeführt
wurde sondern von immigranten
jugendlichen oder es gab gewalt die
jetzt politisch überhaupt nicht mehr
nötig motiviert war
und da bin ich der meinung dass man da
genau die gleichen wege gehen muss und
er werde ich bis war natürlich sagen wir
mal von der sozialromantik von links
angefallen
sozialromantik ist ein schönes stichwort
denn sie haben ein buch geschrieben über
ihre vorstellungen schluss mit der
sozialromantik das ist eine relativ
heftige abrechnung mit der
gegenvorstellung darüber wie man mit
jugendlichen straftätern umgehen sollte
ach so heftig ist es nicht der titel
schluss mit der sozialromantik betrifft
drei sozialromantiker zunächst einmal
betraf mich auch ich hab's
autobiografisch geschrieben als sie
meinen ersten jungen mann in bau
gesteckt habe habe ich am zur medaille
geholt hat er versagt ich wollte mit
mitteln der pädagogik an ich wollte
keinen knacks packen damit trifft die
sozialromantik von links die immer nur
sagt wir warten ab wir warten möglichst
lange ab die nach meinem dafürhalten
mitverantwortlich ist dafür dass wir
heute
etwa 15.000 intensivtäter haben in der
bundesliga deutsche die für 50 bis 60
prozent aller straftaten verantwortlich
sind
es hat sich zwar jetzt ein bisschen
verbessert aber das war über jahrzehnte
so und dann haben auch die
sozialromantik von rechts sowie
konservative sozialromantik die immer
noch meint immer nur mit hut drauf hauen
deswegen bin ich ja nicht wirklich
hättest du richter deutschland ist ja
nicht zu bemessen wie man nur draufhauen
verschärfen der gesetze bringe irgendwas
ist genauso lächerlich eigentlich
kriegen alle ihr fett mit normalen zitat
wo sie sich mit ihren lieblingsgegner
und den linken sozialromantikern
auseinandersetzen
sozialromantik ist reine
täterperspektive da werden die täter zu
opfern gemacht
inwiefern gespielt hast die täter wären
zum opfer gemacht der es glaube ich ein
bisschen aus dem zusammenhang aber es
egal täter werden zu opfern gemacht
indem man zu lange abwartet ein täter
der nicht sieht dass der staat reagiert
dass man ihm jetzt sagt bis hierhin und
nicht weiter
der wird weiter mehrere straftaten
begehen bis er dann viel zu spät beim
jugendrichter landet das heißt auch ein
täter kann opfer eines staatlichen
untätigkeit untätigkeit sein werden
jetzt wird von diesen im anschluss
seinen sozialromantikern gesagt milde
ist besser als strafe weil letztendlich
ist ja auch dieser täter ein opfer weil
er kann nichts für die umstände in denen
er aufgewachsen ist er kann nicht für
sein elternhaus er kann ich für die
armut in der aufgewachsen ist strafe
wäre das falsche wir müssen den
jugendlichen erzielen grunde genommen
ist diese täter sich die dass man sagt
wird schlechter elternhäusern kommt ja
wird sozial schwachen elternhäusern
kommt die wieder nicht richtig erzogen
wurde und so weiter der geburt in sich
die höhere gefahr dass er dann auch zum
gewalttäter oder intensivtäter wird also
kann der täter selber gar nicht so viel
ich mein ich komme auch nicht gerade aus
der besten familie zwar auch wohlig
geschützte meine geschwister aber auch
bei mir sind vorfälle passiert ich
beschreibe und viele viele junge
menschen kommen aus haushalten wo eben
auch alkoholismus einer tür sollen und
die werde ich alle zum verbrecher die
wären nicht alle zum intensivtäter und
diese sichtweise in purer vor angewandt
bedeutet ja die gesellschaft dürfte im
ergebnis nie mit einer knast strafe
reagieren weil sie wir sind ja
mitschuldig daran und diese gedanken
weise erachte ich für falsch
sowohl für die potenziellen opfer die
damit geschaffen wurden in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten als auch für den
täter der den anschluss eine weit höhere
strafe bekommt da sind wir ja beim kendo
auseinandersetzung sie sagen eine
haftstrafe kann auch für jugendliche
manchmal sinnvoll sein
ihre gegner sagen nein das ist völlig
falsch weil die jugendlichen werden erst
dadurch dass man sie in den knast
schickt erst zur richtigen verbrechern
ausgebildet mein bruder saß im knast
jahrelang zu dem zeitpunkt gab es ganz
schlecht die knäste jungs strafvollzug
weil man nicht mehr gesetzlich geregelt
mittlerweile seit fünf jahren gott sei
dank mal geregelt obwohl das auch seit
20 jahren angemahnt wird jugendknast ist
heute schon wesentlich besser als der
den wir vor jahrzehnten hatten
das ist das eine dann ist es so wenn man
wirklich den gedanken hat jugend nass
ist so schlimm
er muss man konsequent sein und weiter
eine verbesserung der jugend knastes
arbeiten was er zurzeit auch gemacht
wird es gibt auch arrest vollzugs
gesetze aber zu sagen
da kommt jeder raus und es noch
schlimmer
das ist quatsch da kommen auch so viele
leute raus
ganz normale bürger werden und in die
gesellschaft zurück kommen ein paar
kommen sicherlich an den paar müssen wir
arbeiten aber deswegen zu sagen das
instrumentarium knast wäre daneben
erklären sie denn auch mal dem opfer 50
tage im krankenhaus gelegen
also machen einige interessante ausflüge
in ihre eigene biografie was sie da
gerade von ihrem bruder erzählt ich
verspreche da komme im verlauf der
sendung noch drauf ich das sehr
interessant finde aber an dem punkt
richtig trotzdem noch bleiben wenn man
so wie ihr kontrahent in der
öffentlichen auseinandersetzung ist der
kriminologe christian pfeiffer dürfte
dem einen oder anderen der zuschauer
bekannt sein
der hat vor immerhin 30 jahren mal eine
große untersuchung gemacht und da hatte
festgestellt dass die rückfallquote bei
tätern die man bei jugendlichen
straftätern die man ins gefängnis
gesteckt hat mit knapp 70 prozent höher
ist als bei den straftätern die man
nicht ins gefängnis geschickt hat
sondern zu sozialpädagogen also ergo im
ergebnis es ist kontraproduktiv
jugendliche straftäter ins gefängnis zu
stecken
perfekt zusammengefasst ist eine studie
aus dem jahre ende 70er jahren in
münchen gemacht und sowohl verglichen
zwischen richter nachrichten und
berichten bösen richtern die ein
bisschen mehr arrest verhängt haben und
nicht so bösen richtern die bisschen
weniger und dann hört man dass gemessen
und dass man zu diesen werken gekommen
man muss ja jetzt im kopf haben das war
ende der 70er jahre die täter von heute
sind andere die haben andere kaliber
teilweise die am andere begehungsweise
wir haben immigranten jugendliche den
biss war ein anders zu begegnen es wir
haben rechtsradikale jugendliche da
müssen wir mit diesen instrumentarien
handeln hinzu kommt es ja rest eine der
70er 80er jahren pädagogisch kaum
ausgerichtet war
heute haben wir schon bisweilen
hervorragende jugendarrestanstalt es
gibt auch eine jüngste studien
ich bezweifle dass ich denke es gibt
rückfallquoten ja die liegen vielleicht
zwischen 30 40
aber dann kann man auch eine an
umgekehrte sicht haben uns sagen dann
haben wir immerhin 60 prozent in die
gesellschaft zurück geholt mit dem
mitteln es kam noch einzeln zu wir
brauchen als jugendrichter die
möglichkeit des freiheitsentzuges auch
als drohung
wir müssen auch den jungs sagen die
keiner rest kriegen wenn wir soweit
macht ja und jetzt kriegt ihr noch eine
arbeitsauflage macht 50 arbeitsstunden
aber wenn wir jetzt noch mal wieder
kommt dann kriegt ihr arrest wohl sagen
sie denn aus ihrer eigenen erfahrung als
jugendrichter wohl macht es sinn
jugendliche wirklich in den knast zu
schicken
also zum beispiel dann wenn sie mehrfach
beim jugendrichter auflaufen also wenn
man wenn er dreimal hintereinander
darauf läuft und in kürzerer zeit erneut
sachen gemacht obwohl arbeitsauflage
bekommen hat obwohl eine weise bekomme
die serie sie dann macht das sinn auch
mit dem härteren mitteln zu agieren
ob das denn erfolgreich sein wird das
weiß ich nicht
ja ich hoffe das natürlich bei einer
guten arrest politik ja dürfte es
erfolgreich sein aber er ist und dass so
auch hier klar zu machen ist kein knast
war es da geht es nur bis zu vier wochen
freiheitsentzug in besonders pädagogisch
ausgerichteten ansteigen die jetzt gott
sei dank mal von unseren deutschen
politikern auch gesetzlich normiert
werden
brandenburg ist gerade dabei in
nordrhein westfalen das haben die
jahrzehnte verpennt aber dann zu sagen
es ist völlig daneben geht gar nicht
wenn ich es nicht gehabt hätte wie vor
opfer hätte ich geschaffen
wenn ich jugendstrafe das ist ja der
wirkliche knast die geht ersten sechs
monate aufwärts nicht bei dem einen oder
anderen rechtsradikalen gewalt hätte
angewandt hätte man mir dem zuständigen
für die erziehung in einem bezirk auf
dem kopf und rappelt diese vorstellung
dass es prinzipiell was falsches sein
könnte jugendliche in den jugendvollzug
zu schicken die geht bis in die höchsten
ebenen
ich würde gerne auf einen fall aus dem
jahr 2010 kommen das ist der so genannte
20 sind fall vielleicht können sie
schildern
was es da geht das war ein fall der
nicht bei ihnen landet die aber der
damals sehr viel schlagzeilen gemacht
hatte ich weiß nicht genau wie alter
waren ein jüngerer mann war unterwegs
der wurde von zwei jugendlichen
heranwachsenden 18 19 wenig reich der
sinne angegriffen und ist dabei zu tode
gekommen er hat das landgericht hamburg
in der ersten instanz
beide täter zu mehrjährigen
jugendstrafen verurteilt
einer davon ist in die revision zum
bundesgerichtshof gegangen und der
bundesgerichtshof hat dann diesen fall
wieder zurück verwiesen und dann hat er
schließlich bewährung bekommen ja durch
das landgericht hamburg nochmals die
eltern konnten es überhaupt nicht
verstehen und dieser junge mann ist denn
drei einige monate nachdem er erneut
bewährung bekommt nochmal wieder
aufgefahren und dann wurde er erst
eingespielt
der bundesgerichtshof sah erzieherische
gesichtspunkten uhr ätherische
gesichtspunkte sind einfach zu beachten
um wendig eine untere instanz zusammen
gericht ein landgericht das nicht
beachtet denn ist es falsch
der fokus liegt nach wie vor in einer
erzieherischen gesichts ein kleines
indiz dafür dass sich in der denke
inzwischen was geändert hat ist der
sogenannte warnschuss-arrest das ist
möglich seit dem frühjahr diesen jahres
was was genau ist das
der warnschussarrest mal gern versuche
ich mir ganz einfach zu erklären
sie haben zwei täter der eine kriegt
eine bewährungsstrafe und der anregung
normalen rs ist ja schon möglich
derjenige der am härtesten verurteilt
wurde der die bewährungsstrafe bekommt
also eine jugendstrafe soll nicht im
knast der sommer an einer rest
schnuppern und dann sagt man ja denn
soll der wenigstens drei wochen mal in
die geringeren frei in den geringeren
freiheitsentzug rein damit er mal
kapiert wie knast freiheitsentzug so
riecht und dieser warnschuss arrest er
ist kein allheilmittel
der ist nach wie vor hoch umstritten er
wird mittlerweile in der bundesrepublik
deutschland praktiziert insbesondere in
den süddeutschen ländern
die schneller sind die sozialdemokratie
hat sich dagegen gesträubt bis zum
gehtnichtmehr habe es nie verstanden
warum die linken genauso die grünen
genauso oder es wurde dann irgendwann
gesetzt weil gewisse wahrscheinlich frau
leutheusser schnarrenberger auch nicht
mehr genau verstanden hat warum man sich
gegen dieses weitere medikament das ist
keine normale freiheitsentzug gewesen
es geht um ein paar wochen arrest da ja
auch eltern verhängen arrest ja daher
nicht mehr gestreut hat deswegen ist es
gott sei dank der rest keine
allheilmittel wenn die rechten meint
dass es mittel ist es genau so ein
quatsch über die linken wollen eine
gruppe von straftätern beschäftigt sie
besonders das sind die sogenannten
intensivtäter sie haben das vorhin schon
gesagt eine relativ kleine gruppe von
straftätern ist für 50 prozent der
straftaten unter den jugendlichen
verantwortlich
ja das sind die wo die sozialromantik
die vorgabe gibt wir warten besser ab
das wächst der irgendwann heraus wenn
wir nur lange genug abwarten und
billigend in kauf nehmen dass der noch
ein paar straftat nie und da begehen
würde wird er irgendwann vielleicht auch
eine ausbildung kam eine leerung es gut
kommt auf verheiratet und familienvater
sein also um das ein bisschen drastisch
sagen intensivtäter diesen begriff hätte
es nie geben dürfen also sie glauben
dass sie als jugendrichter wenn sie
frühzeitig eingreifen zum beispiel durch
den warnschuss arrest oder durch eine
verurteilung zu
diese karriere trainer fest von
überzeugt dass wir wir können also ich
meine in den vergangenen jahrzehnten wie
für intensivtäter sind da gewesen die
sich straftaten begangen haben ohne auch
nur einen einzigen tag freiheitsentzug
bekommen zu haben
und das können wir einfach nicht
hinnehmen das versteht kein opfer wie
ein junger gewalttäter durch die gegend
läuft und jetzt die vierte oder fünfte
geweihter straftat und dafür nicht mehr
einen tag oder eine woche oder
vielleicht einen monat oder zwei monate
auch im knast sitzt das ist
nicht dass es hausgemacht diese
intensivtäter problematik kann man
verringern da braucht man eine
wunderbare vernetzung zwischen allen
beteiligten institutionen
angefangen beim jugendamt über die
polizei die staatsanwalt gericht eine
ganz schnelle reaktion auf jede straftat
in dieser gemacht wird das sind zwei
gesichtspunkte den brauchen wir so ein
zentralregister wo jeder jugendliche der
auffällig ist auffällig wo wir mehr und
wiederholt in der schenke sofort am
nächsten tag dem erziehungs richter
nämlich mir gemeldet wird damit man weiß
der macht weiter und das muss nicht sein
und ich halte es nach wie vor für ein
unding dass einige wenige tausende
jugendliche oder heranwachsende egal ob
sie jetzt deutsches blut haben oder
immigranten blut verantwortlich für
sophie taten sind und das kann der staat
nicht länger dulden und da gibt's
instrumentarien für es gibt einige
einige beispiele das inzwischen doch
einige jugendrichter ähnlich denken wie
sie ich greife mal den spektakulärsten
fall heraus den wir in den letzten
monaten erlebt hat das war hier in
berlin am alexanderplatz der fall von
monika der von drei jugendlichen mit
migrationshintergrund von vier
jugendlichen letztendlich zu tode
geprügelt wurde
der haupttäter ist am ende verurteilt
worden zu vier jahren und sechs monaten
ohne bewährung das klingt zunächst mal
milde aber vergleichen was mal mit der
ansicht des bundesgerichtshofs im 20
cent fall vor drei jahren dann merkt man
die justiz handelt heute heute anders
als vor drei jahren
ich bin der festen überzeugung obwohl es
auch statistisch natürlich nicht messbar
die kresse leeren sich langsam das wird
von den gegnern
all das wird ja gar nicht so hart
geurteilt und ich sage gerade weil es
hart geurteilt wird hat das ganze auch
abschreckungswirkung im fall
alexanderplatz prozess da sind sextäter
gewinn
lesen sextäter den wurde letztlich eine
körperverletzung nachgewiesen und einem
haupttäter eine körperverletzung mit
todesfolge
die hat viereinhalb jahre bekommen
teilweise noch jugendstrafrecht
teilweise nach erwachsenen straftäter
hat bewährung bekommen und das waren zum
teil erst täter dabei
ich finde das ist das zeigt dass die
justiz anzieht
wir haben früher die alt 68er gehabt die
für alt für die alt 68er was das
schlimmste überhaupt knast zu verhängen
diese generation das bin nicht die
generation die jetzt am wirken ist die
generation kirsten heisig die generation
nach 68 die urteil teilweise ehrte mit
der folge allerdings dass wir
letztendlich weniger einen knast
schicken müssen
ich habe vorhin gesagt dass ich nicht
aussparen möchte die interessanten
aspekte ihrer in ihrem lebenslauf
die meisten richter kommen aus einem
wohl situierten bürgerlichen elternhaus
bei ihnen war eher das gegenteil der
fall
das kann man so nicht sagen das problem
in meiner familie war ein alkoholkranker
vater sondern zeit wo es noch nicht so
als krankheit angesehen wurde und was
damit einher ging mein bruder geriet auf
abwege auf abwege ging in die hippie
szene verkaufte keiner bis weil dann im
heim und zwar im pädagogisch schlechten
heim online es ist schließlich im knast
der kleine andreas es war ich ja hatte
quasi das glück nicht alles um
mitzubekommen ging der north gymnasium
obwohl er hier und da seine probleme
hatte lispelt
deutschen nicht gut lese
rechtschreibschwäche hyperaktiv ist
wahrscheinlich auch ich hätte
wahrscheinlich so alles gekriegt was man
so von psychologen kriegen kann und bin
dann eben ohne vater und bruder
aufgewachsen und durch einen
katholischen orden aus dem gymnasium zum
abitur gebracht worden also ganz so
schlimm war es nicht so aus das ist
zutreffend wenn ich ein bisschen älter
gewesen wäre die umstände ein bisschen
anders denn hätte ich auch in die andere
richtung gehen können wenn ich nicht das
glück gehabt hätte
das zum richtigen zeitpunkt die
richtigen leute an der richtigen stelle
war und teilweise waren die natürlich
auch so so patrice die haben teilweise
natürlich auch so mit klaren ansagen und
sie aber nicht nein die party ist
alleine auch nicht keine ahnung es war
vielleicht auch die abschreckung des
bruders ich mein mann mein bruder war
schon im casting konnte der kleine
bruder hinterher geh ich musste auf
irgendeine art die familienehre auch
wiederherstellen und das konnte ich im
abitur aber da sind viele sachen die da
zusammenkommen weil ich will damit
einfach nur sagen grundsätzlich zu sagen
da kommt die man aus schlechten haushalt
dann hat er eben auch das recht
irgendwie quer zu gehen das geht nicht
war das auch so ein motiv weil sie dann
dass sie dann am ende die richter wurden
die familienehre wiederherstellen ich
glaube deswegen will ich in jurist
geworden sondern auch querkopf
nein das motiv natürlich ich kann mich
noch erinnern als meine mutter denn mit
bekam das war kurz vor ihrem tod
ich habe jetzt eine richterstelle ja der
war sie überglücklich das war natürlich
klasse jetzt hebbt wi en plein richter
einer familie und ich würde sie nicht
ausruhen
viel von dem was sie so im lauf der
sendung gesagt haben das klingt so nach
konservativer hardliner jetzt muss man
aber mal anmerken dass sie durchaus mal
ein ausflug in die politik gemacht haben
aber es und sie haben auch kandidiert
aber für die pds wie passt denn das
zusammen
ich passe mich vorher das
zusammenzubringen
wer nun ist links seien ja auch deshalb
so man ist links wenn man opfer schützen
ist für die schwächeren eigentlich da
man möchte dass alle auf irgendeiner art
beschützt werden und so weiter das ist
auch links und ich setze mich dafür ein
dass wir weniger opfer haben dass wir
die opfer von den tätern schützen und
nicht umgekehrt
insoweit passt das sehr wohl dass haben
nur linke noch nicht so verstanden meine
meine denke deswegen kann ich links
eigentlich bin nicht mehr links ich bin
weder rechts ich bin wieder links ich
bin wieder rosig wie der grün
ich habe keine farbe ich bin im
sachverstand verpflichtet in der
sachverstand hat mich dazu gebracht das
eine oder andere an zu machen
insbesondere die schnelligkeit die ja
man ja auch von kirsten heisigs schon
angemahnt bekommen hat das wird nach wie
vor nicht gemacht und wenn wir nicht
aufpassen in dieser gesellschaft und
jetzt im moment nur darauf gucken dass
wir rückläufige zahlen haben die haben
wir meine gegner
die sahen wie die zahlen sind alle
rückläufig klar sind sie rückläufig wenn
wir keine jungen arbeitslosigkeit machen
und die jungen menschen perspektiven
haben denn sind sie rückläufig
warten wir zwei jahre ab und die
wirtschaft geht im eimer und wir sind
nicht geschützt
dann haben wir das gleiche
gewaltpotenzial auf der straße und noch
viel schlimmer
ich schreibe also mein buch
mit blick auf die vergangenheit
gerichtet allerdings auf die zukunft zur
vermeidung weiterer opfer und opfer
vermeidung halte ich für linkes ziel
ich habe bereits vor zehn jahren unter
anderem gefordert auch bei der
linkspartei opferschutz gehört genauso
wie genauso wie tierschutz ins
grundgesetz
und er mehrfach erwähnt haben sie
christen heilig die richterin aus berlin
sie hat mit ihrem buch das ende der
geduld ganz ähnliche thesen vertreten
wie seal wm haben sie zusammengearbeitet
letztendlich waren gute freunde über
kirsten steht in diesem buch auch über
ihren werdegang wie sie zu deutschlands
bekanntesten richterin geworden ist was
sie mit ihrem neuköllner modell wollte
und auch die letzten begebenheiten im
zusammenhang mit ihrem tod ich würde mir
im grunde zwei kapitel in diesem buch
wir haben zusammen ich hätte dir den
ersten dank mit stefan coperion in ihrem
buch
sie hatte damals schon einige fälle in
ihrem buch von mir wir haben über das
buch geredet sie kritisch begleitet und
sie war großartig hatte das neuköllner
modell entwickelt das ist leider gottes
bisher nur nach bayern zu den rechten in
anführungsstrichen exportiert worden
berlin macht es noch mein eigenes
bundesland ich mein zimmer an
sie hat sie hat sie hat die wunde die
hände in die wunde gelegt sie hat
klargemacht dass schnelligkeit ganz ganz
wichtig ist zur vermeidung von
intensivtätern ja und ich hab jetzt eben
noch mal ein bisschen nachgelegt
bisschen anders ganz anders geschrieben
autobiografisch geschrieben ist nicht zu
vergleichen mit carsten heise ich
schreibe auch über mein leben und aus
den erfahrungen und in der hoffnung auch
das andenken von kissen reise ich
irgendwann meine köpfe aller deutschen
politiker gelangt unabhängig von ihrer
ideologischen ausrichtung gästen reisig
hat
im juni 2010 er leben beendet haben sie
eine idee eine vorstellung warum jobs
geschrieben weil mich immer wieder
menschen an jetzt kann doch nicht sein
dass eine so großartige jugendrichterin
system genommen hat ja das kann sein
es kann sein dass ich heute depression
wird bereits schon mal selbstmordversuch
hinter sich
ich hab sie wiederholt auch im vorfeld
getroffen
ja sie war einfach müde von leben
sie hätte vielleicht nicht mehr genügend
geduld mit sich selber in gewisser weise
haben sie die ideen den kampf von von
kess sind heiße ich jetzt aufgenommen
führen dass weiter gehen an die
öffentlichkeit machen auch für kirsten
heisigs ideen der punkt was würde sie
gerne erreichen
also ich dann lange vor kirchen heiße
schon in der öffentlichkeit die ersten
torschuss habe ich 2002 gemacht auf
kissen begleitet das würde ich gerne
erreichen ich würde gerne erreichen dass
vieles von dem was wir in unseren köpfen
ab und wir sind nicht die einzigen die
meisten jugendrichter teilen dass das
ist ein streit zwischen theorie und
praxis theorie ja sagt wir müssen es so
machen die praxis im großen und ganzen
teilt die nicht jedes detail was hier
drin steht jede gedanken nicht jeden
gedanken in kissen heißt aber das große
und ganze wird geteilt was möchte ich
erreicht was möchte ich erreichen wenn
ich nur ein prozent opfer vermeiden
durch mein reden in torschuss in dem ich
interviews gibt in dem ich den einen
oder anstoßen oder anderen anschluss dem
einen oder anderen politiker gäbe ja
dann versteckt möglicherweise meine
gedanken als gesetzt wenn die landtage
oder in den bundestag bringt dann habe
ich eine menge gemacht
erreichen möchte ich dass man jetzt
nicht hingeht die hände in den schoß
legt und sagt die zahlen
und dann habe ich in zwei jahren die
gleiche kriminalität wie sie anfang 2000
hatte dann habe ich rechtsradikalismus
wieder dies oder jenes
jugendgruppengewalt ich will die nicht
mehr in den öffentlichen raum die
gehören nicht hin
das war der dialog heute mit dem
jugendrichter andreas müller hat vielen
dank